good morning in the West and good
afternoon here on the East Coast I'm
building Airmen the director of
infectious diseases at J craig Venter
Institute and today I want to talk to
you about a specialist fumigatus
invasive aspergillosis and some aspects
of treating invasive aspergillosis with
basal drugs so first looking at this
disease and and how it's really
dependent on the host status so John
pehle jayegi
described as the jealous Fuma goddess as
really a grass eater it's not a pathogen
it's ubiquitous everywhere on the planet
practically it's in our homes it's in
our lawns it's on the walls of our
offices so we gaily breathe in several
hundred spores the so called Canadia
from a specialist from adidas but we
don't come down with the disease because
of the fact that under our normal immune
system the alveolar macrophages per
Joseph Wilma Gaeta spores it's only
under cases of immune dysfunction where
you actually get invasive aspergillosis
in either subacute or acute stages and
so it's actually relatively recently in
human history that invasive
aspergillosis has been something that
we've even noticed the reasons are for
it are something I'll talk about in a
bit but then on the other end of the
immune status scale is immune hyper
reactivity in individuals such as those
with severe asthma under those
circumstances the regular exposure
Aspergillus force results in
colonization that can really lead to
problems where or you've got a fungi
colonizing the sinuses and colony and
causing this allergic bronchopulmonary
aspergillosis so that you know in normal
immune system there are these other
conditions that are listed here but
these are really low incidence
circumstances that that in fact we are
in normal immune state is very effective
at dealing with the fungal spores that
we encounter in our daily lives so in
the cases of immune compromised folks
the leading cause of mortality is
invasive the spiritual artists for these
infectious mortality for these folks
it's increased in incidence simply due
to the fact that our medical successes
have given us a longer life expectancy
so so we actually are an aging
population relative to human historical
time and the additional component that
causes this increased incidence is the
fact that our medical technologies
particularly transplant tissue
transplant and chemotherapy for treating
cancer leads to immune suppression and
the immune suppression makes us
vulnerable to infections by these these
spores that it's very difficult to avoid
the mortality for invasive aspergillosis
is is between 50 and 80 percent for a
couple of reasons one of the reasons is
that it's really fairly difficult
diagnosed and so typical diagnosis comes
in after the infection is really pretty
well-established and and the other issue
is which is going to be something that
that's going to need your part of the
talk is that the drugs that are used for
trying to manage and basically us as
patients really are not very efficacious
and so in the absence of
you know these really really affected
drugs and the late diagnosis we seen
mortalities at these levels so I've
indicated a medical law transplant
technologies contributing to these
diseases group of diseases that are
genetic the innate immune deficiencies
also are exposed to high risk in
particular chronic granulomatous disease
has a high lifetime incidence also lung
transplantation in particular has a high
lifetime risk but most most of the
people that get this are our bone marrow
transplants or or new treating patients
that are undergoing chemotherapy so
having looked at the human side let's
now look at the fungus the Aspergillus
agents that actually caused these
diseases the image here is of
espadrilles Fuma gaiters you can see the
filaments on the colony on the left and
you can see that that gray green color
that's that's the sport color the sport
coat pigment and you see these
microscopic images of these fruiting
bodies in the fungi that produced these
spores in particular for Aspergillus
fumigatus the spore size is really small
compared to other Aspergillus species
and this certainly facilitates that
being dispersed by air and also when we
breathe these things in the small size
really results in deep penetration and
lower respiratory tract which by
contributes to the disease from a
clinical presentation you see in
opacities and the regions are the lungs
and in in boxes a and B and where you
see indicated by the circles and the
arrows our areas of
hi fungal burden by CT scan you can see
these these concentrated fungal
infection sites indicated by the arrows
in C and in D you actually can see a
consolidation of a portion of the lung
that's resulted by the severe tissue
damage that's resulted from this fungal
infection the nutria neutrophil
ingression
is shown in in e the the fungus having
invaded the lung tissue really caused as
a recruitment of the neutrophils which
actually causes a lot of the damage in
the case of invasive aspergillosis and
you can see and laugh by staining for
the fungus you can you can see the
filaments actually within the lung
tissue light microscopy the illusions
are clear you can actually see the
filaments by staining them with
something like calico flora white which
makes them readily apparent with within
these legion lesions so I've been
talking about Aspergillus fumigatus
Aspergillus fumigatus for most of the
world is the leading cause of invasive
aspergillosis but the fact of the matter
is there's something like 200
Aspergillus species that have been
identified it's noteworthy to point out
that only about seven of these species
have been reported to have caused
invasive disease the second most
prevalent Aspergillus that causes this
disease is Aspergillus flavus and
there's actually parts of the world
where Aspergillus flavus is the primary
the major cause of the maze of the
spiritual OSIS what I'm showing you here
is a very recent report by our
collaborators Jenna Sugie and Jun Kwan
Chung
where they identified a new species of
pathogenic Aspergillus Aspergillus which
they named tanner i it's only been known
to have killed two patients so far
they were there at the clinical center
there's a large respiratory service at
the clinical center at the NIH campus in
Bethesda and so the severe cases
particularly the GCD patients get
referred to the clinical center when
they're really having difficulty
managing them in their in their home
medical facilities a particular
attribute of this this new fungus is
that it's resistant to every known
antifungal that's used for managing the
disease and so so for two diagnosed
infections that both both led to the
death of the patients now looking at a
project because as I indicated there's
more than one fungus that can cause
invasive aspergillosis so so here I want
to go to talking about how do you like
identify variants factors in these and
so I'm gonna just give you some examples
espadrille Astaire I really has given us
an opportunity to see different views of
virulence so here is shown three models
of these are invert these are animal
models of invasive aspergillosis the
upper panel a uses Marvin black smoke
larva Gallery and Mellon Ella we use
this in our lab it's a really
inexpensive approach to doing pre
vertebrate animal burials testing at
much less cost and a lot of the findings
that are noted in this system actually
carry over to showing variance in the
mouse models so the green is the percent
survival for those infected with
Aspergillus flavus
in this model Aspergillus flavus
certainly is the obvious most virulent
of these three species the tannery and
Bloor is
and Aspergillus fumigatus is actually
the least virulent in this model when
you drop down to the belt see mice panel
B this mouse model uses cortisone
suppression and in the the the way this
is set up using the immune expression is
to try to mimic as much as possible at
the mouse model the suppression
conditions under you know tissue
transplant or eliminar transplants in
humans and in this model you see that
the all three
Aspergillus species seem to be
exhibiting fairly similar patterns
percent survival in this experiment and
then GCD mice now in GCD these mice the
innate immune cells do not have the
ability to generate reactive oxygen and
so as a consequence of this there are a
bit defective in the ability to kill
microbes and and humans with CTD are
particularly susceptible as you saw in
an earlier slide to invasive
aspergillosis and in this model
Aspergillus fumigatus is the more severe
pathogen while the other two really are
exhibiting very little killing of their
Co over the course of this experiment so
so the three models here really just
give different profiles for these
pathogenic as per July here as a
taxonomic tree these three as per July
shown here filming Gators tannery
flavors highlighted within this
taxonomic tree are lots of species of
Aspergillus that never appear in
clinical cases and so there's something
about these three that make them then
really different than their their other
members of the genus all of these
organisms essentially compete in the
same soil environment
they've all established the ability to
can be successfully in this environment
and since since the human infection is
really a dead end for this fungus it's
not a normal part of their life cycles
they've all developed the capabilities
of surviving in an immune suppressed
human as a consequence of the selection
they've experienced in the soil and the
obvious example that that people cite in
talking about this virulence traits
acquired in the soil environment is that
undoubtedly these fungi regularly
encounter Ameobi
and in the soil and the ability to
survive and amoebae from the perspective
of the fungus that requires pretty much
the same skill set us to survive in
human macrophage presumably so just as
an aside we've done transcriptome
analysis with the landing now at in in
the UK at Imperial College in London
with flava sand Fuma Gaydos and both of
these fungi in the mouse lungs really
increase the expression of sets of
clusters of genes that Elaine is labeled
as virulence clusters because presumably
these things are induced in the stress
of the amalong environment to allow
survival they are but note a separate
observation we made in our group with
Natalie roba contributing to this is
that the clusters these clusters are in
accessory regions of the genome these
are genes that are not dispersed
throughout the Aspergillus genus but are
fairly unique to the species and so
clusters of genes are up expressed in
mouse lungs and fumigatus they're up
expressed in mouse lungs and flavas but
the fact is that these clusters of genes
have very little sequence relatedness
between these two species and so our
hypothesis here is is that
these fungi meet the same sorts of
challenges in the mouse environment but
they use different tools that they've
acquired from there environmental
exposure environmental selection to be
able to survive here and so we're gonna
do an exhaustive comparative analysis
between flavors tannery and through
michaelis to see if we can really come
up with some understanding of the range
of functions within these fungi that are
essential for establishing these
invasive infections with him within
within humans audience questions so
getting on to two more what I'm trying
to make the key components of this
presentation is how we manage invasive
especially spiritual assist patients in
the clinic so everybody is well aware of
the crisis and infectious diseases that
is maturing due to drug resistance in
bacterial antibiotics but compared to
the bacterial problem it's much more
severe in the fungi bacteria have many
more classes of targets because bacteria
prokaryotes and the patient's the humans
are eukaryotes and there's a lot of
metabolic instructional differences
between the prokaryotes and the
eukaryotes this is not true for the
fungi fungi or eukaryotes just as we are
and there's actually in looking
specifically at drug targets for
treating in basic the spiritual OSIS
there's only three classes of drugs and
they're targeting only two differences
between humans and fungi
so the polyenes and the easels take
advantage of the fact that in fungal
cell membranes the stirol' is
ergo stroke whereas in human cells the
stir all is cholesterol and so this
difference this relatively subtle
difference is actually allowing for
these two classes of drugs the
ergosterol polyenes actually target the
nostril and membrane and the easels
inhibit the production of guster all the
third category kind of canned ins take
advantage of the fact that fungi have a
cell wall and and human cells do not and
so this inhibits critical enzyme and
fungal cell wall biosynthesis so you
know just again in diagram here the poly
means specifically for treating invasive
Spiritualist eccentric terrorists and be
binds to the nostril and the membranes
and the easels several easels that have
been developed for treatment disease and
the easels are are the primary drug for
treating invasive aspergillosis inhibit
the biosynthetic pathway of synthesis of
varicose well and so here is the cell
membrane diagram and the cell wall of
fungi is in three layers there's man and
on the outside there's that blook an
intermediate layer and then the inner
layer is chitin next to the cell
membrane the enzyme inhibited by the
canyons is the beta 1 3 glucan synthase
switch actually polymerizes the sugars
into making their the beta 1 3 glycan of
the cell wall structure so a plethora
Simbi is actually produced as a natural
product by streptomyces it binds to stir
all just mentioned and actually creates
pores in the membrane that result in
electrolyte and small molecule leakage
that that causes the cells to die the
kind of Camden's are cyclic
Lippo peptide antibiotics they as i
indicated by their that beta 1 3 gloopy
and synthesis they're analogous to the
beta-lactam antibiotics for treating
bacterial diseases bacterial infections
because they cause a defective cell wall
to be made which results in my fragility
and so cell lysis
but the primary okay and show and
showing where where the glucan is
synthesized in in the elongated
filaments of the fungus fungal filaments
grow from the apical end and you can see
by the staining of infantile a with
antiserum to the enzyme they're the glue
canson states that it's concentrated at
the end of the filament by staying for
specifically for the beta 1 3 glue key
and you can also see that that most the
most abundant buzz location of the glue
can is in the growing apical chip but
the major drugs that are used for
treating invasive aspergillosis are the
Hazel's and these are well what's shown
here circled in right this ketoconazole
is classically a easels called
imidazoles they had this active
imidazole ring that contains two
nitrogens and a saturated five-member
aromatic wing
circled in red is the trials that have
the the three nitrogens within the five
membered ring these asel 's inhibit the
enzyme that the g name is earth 11 it's
an enzyme that actually takes lanister
all underly stir all in the biosynthetic
pathway to ergosterol and performs an
additional step in taking it to the
ergosterol so it's a cytochrome p450 the
enzyme is a sterile 14 alpha d methylase
and it's responsible for this conversion
and the hazel's actually binded this
enzyme and there's there's been
structural studies performed on how
these asel compounds fit into the active
site of this enzyme so looking first at
you know i'm shifting into a discussing
drug resistance now and so so here's
across the top is these East strip 4e
tests for drug resistance where you grow
the fungi on plates you lay the strip on
as you go down the strip you have
increasing concentrations of the anti
fungal and this diffuses into the medium
and it's calibrated using other tests to
allow visual reading of the minimum
inhibitory concentration of the drug on
the fungus and so you see Aspergillus
fumigatus the first sequence strain AF
293 is sensitive to both Boreanaz all
and amphotericin B and then in the
adjacent panels are the two isolates
that killed the two patients of
Aspergillus teri you can see coloration
difference around the strip's but in
fact the
the colonies the the fungi grow right up
against the strip so these these have
resistance completely to the range of
these test strips and this is the
problem in in many patients because the
the Hazel's are relatively ineffective
and the result of that is that the need
for long-term maintenance of patients on
on easels the fungus develops our
resistance over time
so the MIS diagram you see the two sort
of classes of trial drugs the a and B's
the post comics all and it ricasso have
these long chains you can you can see
the trial rings they're in lower parts
of the left end of these molecules and
those look quite different than the
simpler compounds
baura Kanazawa c and and fluconazole as
d so i indicated that structural studies
have been done with crystallized protein
and and crystallization of the protein
and the presence of the easels and and
the colored balls so on the left is a
pose a connoisseur which has that long
tail of a long tail on the nasal
compound which I've circled in red the
one on the right is vorak on is all is
in the same same protein the diagram
shows three sites where sequence
alterations at these sites confer
resistance to some or all easels also
you see those that green structure
that's a heme molecule and the the
triazole shown the triazole ring shown
in the Burrow Kanazawa panel b is
sitting on top of the iron really which
inhibits
the oxidation reduction capabilities of
the heme is a cofactor for this compound
and so you can see how this g54 in panel
a is in very close proximity to this
tail and alterations with other G's for
glycine and when something other than
glycine is at this site you do get
resistance to the post Akana salt but
maybe but but not with boric honest all
and you can see that there's that G 54
site the glycine 54 site it's actually
quite removed in the absence of that
tail on me easel so in this way you can
see that that some alterations in this
that's Erb 11 also called set 51 stir
all the methylase confers resistance to
only some of the angels or it confers
resistance to all of the easels is this
glycine alteration at position 4 for 8
confers resistance to all of the easels
so there's there's a lot of sequencing
that's been done on resistant strains a
lot of positions have been mutated and
been shown to contribute to resistance
in addition there's Tam duplications in
the promoter of this gene that results
in over expression this has never been
observed to clinical isolates but it
hadn't been observed and Aspergillus
fungus harvested from the environment
and one of the confounding things of all
this well of the conventional wisdom is
that 51a the ERG 11 gene this this
dimethyl ace d methylase is the target
of the easels there's a lot of strains
out there that are resistant dazzles for
which there's no mutations in this gene
that that are cannot be used to account
for this resistance so is this
resistance important well
as I indicated many patients are on
long-term is all therapy because the
need for treating for such a long time
to clear the infection and so in the
course of long duration nasal treatment
the organism goes under undergoes
replication and mutations and the
selection and presence of the drug
really selects for drug-resistant
strains so in invasive aspergillosis
mortality to when the strain that's
isolated so it's sensitive is the thirty
to fifty percent i indicated earlier but
once you convert to a resistant strain
or if you're initially infected with the
hospital outbreak from a resistant
strain that's that's gone through
multiple patients the mortality
progresses in mortality is now eighty
eight percent so this is a dramatic
difference in and prognosis based on the
resistance status to easels by that by
the fungus and as i indicated the reason
you know we in the manchester group
though we collaborate with getting where
they've got a sort of a national center
for invasive aspergillosis 10 to 50
percent of their are isolates from
patients that are resistant to easels do
not carry alterations in this change so
so it appears from on the surface that
resistance dazzles is much more
complicated than a single target so
because of this we've launched a study
in collaboration with the manchester
group and in collaboration with Jim qin
qiong at the clinical center to really
apply a multi-faceted approach to
identifying resistance modulating genes
in the genome of
Aspergillus fumigatus and really one of
the things we want to accomplish in this
study because there's so few drugs that
can even be applied to treat this
disease is to identify candidate drug
targets or Co drug targets for
subsequent drug development to really
offer some some greater opportunity for
actually managing patients with this
disease and so we're using four
different approaches it's really just
three approaches with the last
confirming that the alterations we find
actually have relevance for clinical
isolates because we've seen the same
alterations in those clinical isolates
so the the a approach is is transposon
sequencing TN seek all of these
approaches use next-generation
high-throughput sequencing as the key
technology for for determining the
findings so TN seek is probably the most
powerful of the three approaches here TN
seek has the ability to look at every
gene in the genome and evaluate its
fitness under under some selective
pressures and of course the selective
pressures we want to impose here are
stresses from from asel drugs and so so
it employs a large library of clones of
Aspergillus fumigatus each member of the
library
as a separate clone with a single
transposon inserted in a gene causing a
loss of function in that gene in that
particular particular individual member
of the library and in the library is
passage under selective pressure we put
some level of Hazel's for passage
conditions
and then the relative abundance of each
member of the library is determined
before and after the passage and because
a clone that is resistant more resistant
to the A's all on passage is going to
grow faster than one that is sensitive
by measuring the relative abundance of
each of the clones with transposons in a
single gene each you can actually
calculate the Fitness contribution of
that gene
under those passage conditions the don't
worry about the details of this slide
the the stuff this is a bacterial
cheonsik process it actually turns out
being a bit more complicated and
Aspergillus fumigatus for what what he
did and so this was a much easier way to
said just be aware that the first step a
is making your library by putting a
transposon into a large number of your
your fungal set fungal spores fungal
clones and so that that in such a
fashion that each of the resultant
individuals has a transposon that's at a
unique site in a gene or in an energetic
region within the fungus and this is
this is your trigger TN seek library
then you take your library inline be
passing to through asel in vitro passage
conditions that's going to put pressure
on the members of the library most of
the genes aren't going to affect the
survivability or the growth rate in the
drug and so their their abundance is not
going to change some genes when there
has but transposon resulting in a loss
of function are going to
make that individual member of the
library a better competitive if it's
actually making it less sensitive to the
drug or less competitive it's making
more sensitive to the drug and so this
gives you a relative measure of the
fitness contribution of that gene
through this process and the way you
evaluate that is by in-line see going
through a procedure totally different
than the one illustrated here which
captures specifically pieces of DNA
adjacent to the site of the insertion so
that you can actually identify what gene
the transposon is inserted in that
strain and then these captured regions
of genomic DNA adjacent to the
transposon are then sequencing using an
Illumina sequencer and the sequence
reads on that back to the genome and and
each read reflects individual and
library that was present in either the
before condition or after passage or
both and you can you can actually by
looking at the numbers of reads before
and after for a particular gene get a
measure of the fitness of that gene
under the under pressure of being
passaged in in the asel drug so our
collaborators at the University of
Manchester have made the library the
gene count and Espinosa Fuma gaiters is
about ten thousand there's not two
thousand genes in espadrilles from
Adidas and they made a very large
library that contains five hundred
thousand individual clones each of them
having a different insertion site for
the transposon so this is this is very
good coverage of the genome then the
library was passage by them in 16 times
the minimum
inhibitory concentration of a true
connoisseur and then it was analyzed by
relative abundance of the clones before
and after passage and this analysis
revealed actually 387 jeans with
strongly altered fitness that is these
387 genes either made the clone
containing them in the untransformed
unknown transposed state they these are
the functional versions of the gene
either increase resistance to a salts
thus a zoetic özil or they decrease it
so it makes it more sensitive or more
resistant and so it actually plays in
the response of the organism of the
fungus to the challenge some of these
genes of course it identified the SIP
51a that's the lannister all demethylase
but there's also a lot of other kinds of
genes that seem to be important for asel
survival or sensitivity including
transcriptional regulators t not trna
modifying enzymes just a whole lot of
things and then a lot of genes of
unknown function so this is telling us
that it makes sense that there's a lot
of strains coming out of patients that
are resistant to a zoals
that do not have a mutation in the SIP
51a gene because there's a lot of genes
in the genome of this organism that that
acts on the sensitivity or resistance to
a zoals
so that was our first strategy the
second strategy was simply taking us to
two strains of Aspergillus fumigatus
that were nearly isogenic
and that'll be important in a minute
when we talk about the next strategy and
passage Ingham first round simply at a
sub inhibitory concentration of four
results we did this with with with four
different easels and then we passage
them at four X M I see four X to the
minimum inhibitory concentration in step
four and pick for individual clones from
each of the passage conditions I mean we
pick three I'm sorry there's it's three
as shown there so we pick three
individual clones and then we passage
those through a second round of drug
challenge this time eight times the
minimum inhibitory concentration and
then for each of those we picked another
three and so we ended up with I think
something like thirty two different
isolates from two different levels of
drug resistance and we sequence the
genomes of all of these and look for
changes relative to the drug sensitive
initial parent and so we've got lots of
variations and and so I'll put this
together in a minute but we used their
very highly resistant parents both
mating types in a sexual cross
experiment where we took three different
resistant isolates that had been through
this election and and crossed them with
the other mating type starting sensitive
parent and so it's only been in the last
several years that you've been able to
have in betrayal conditions for having
sexual crosses within an Aspergillus
fumigatus and Jim Kwan Chung and Janice
surgery developed conditions that make
this much more efficient than the early
reports that require something like six
months for a single man single single
cross and so in this experiment we did
these crosses with parents from all of
the different
easels that we did in the previous
selection experiments in vitro and then
did the crosses and then collected the
ascospores now the ascospores are the
sexual progeny of the cross and we
passage the the pool of ascospores under
three conditions no drug selection and
then for x mi c and then 8 x mi c and
the no selection should give us equal
representation of the variations in the
genomes because there's no drug pressure
at all and so that's a nice control that
that crossing went as expected and then
at the intermediate and high levels we
expected to see enrichments for all of
the genetic variations all of the snips
the genetic alleles coming from the
resistance strain enriched in these
populations and then our last approach
in with the clinical Center at the
University of Manchester in the UK with
David dinning and pub wire
they sent us 36 total clinical isolates
16 of these had a zone resistance and 28
were sensitive and some of these 16
resistant ones were sequential isolates
that had different levels of basal
resistance from the same from the same
patient so we could actually see the
progression of resistance within the
same patient in some of these and then
we sequenced all of these and and then
identified snips snips single nucleotide
polymorphisms differences across all
these so some of these isolates had no
sip 51a a resistance which was you know
consistent with what we'd seen before
and I'd mentioned that some of these
were consecutive eye slits but but one
thing I want to indicate is is that
these these are unrelated strains and
unrelated strains have a high background
of numbers of snips between them so what
we wanted to do with this set of
isolates is to look back at the things
we found through processes a B and C and
see if we see the same same mutations
coming up in the clinical eye slits
because you could make the case that
everything we've done in a B and C are
only in vitro manipulation of the
organism and it's conceivable that it
could be artifacts so we really wanted
to use these sequencing in clinical
isolates just as a validation that we
see the same kinds of variation within
the clinical population as we see in our
in vitro analysis this is just a quick
look at some of the enzymes in the
gastro biosynthetic pathway from these
clinical isolates and you know the red
strain and the green strain are
resistant and sensitive and you can in
the bass change in the DNA sequences
shown at the very end of the middle
column there's a lot of differences
between these strains I think the number
of steps between any two unrelated
Aspergillus fumigatus strain is
something like 70 or 80 thousand snips
so this is not a very robust way of
finding resistance genes but it is
a good way of seeing what is present in
in clinical isolates and so this is sort
of a summary table of condensed for a
much huger data set so what what's shown
here is the mutations that led to drug
resistance using our various approaches
and so as I indicated that en seek which
is the third column over identified two
genes within the Aircast total pathway
as essential one is this Kirk 1151 a
that I've talked most about essential
meaning that when you put a transpose on
in this gene that's a that's a lethal
event for that individual clone so we
never saw transposons in those and so
that's how we knew it was essential this
HMG co-reductase had to hydroxymethyl
ruderal COI reductase is an interesting
story because it was noted some time ago
that statins statins that are drugs for
reducing cholesterol in human they come
from from aspergillosis
and other filamentous fungi but statins
inhibit human hydroxy this is the firt
one of the early enzymes in the
synthesis of cholesterol and so these
are using to analyze request role and so
so presumably this gene which we found
mutated in all of our approaches is also
modulates the resistance to to the
athens and then you see these other
things here you see scores for both
things that contribute to resistance and
contribute to sensitivity through some
of these other factors and actually the
list is is much much larger than this
there's validation across all three of
these columns so that we're seeing the
same mutations at some level using all
over the approaches although TNC really
gives us a very high-resolution view of
the role or the quantitative role of
gene playing in drug resistance so so
what we have now is a very large set of
drugs targets that can serve as drug
targets for drugs or core drugs and
which we've identified using multiple
technical approaches here which I I
think the approach makes it very robust
we've certainly seen based on initial
observations that a lot of days all
resistance isn't resulting from sip
51:18 mutations but is resistance
actually is broadly polygenic with lots
of genes contributing to resistance or
sensitive phenotypes and even within a
set 51a particularly with the two
different classes of easels there's
multiple alterations within these this
gene that leads to resistance there's an
even larger number of alterations which
has no effect on resistance this is
really one a gene within the genome
which has a very high rate of mutation
on propagation I don't know if this is
an adaption to to evolutionary pressure
from hazel's in the soil but certainly
compared to most places in the
Aspergillus fumigatus genome we see a
much greater variation even in the
absence of any drug considerations
within the set 5118 then
most of the other genes in the genome so
with that I want to credit the
University of Manchester group Paul
player and David Denny and the NIH
Clinical Center Jana suji and June Kwan
Chung for the major contributions they
made to this project and within a group
of JCB I Stephanie when I worked with me
in developing the drug resistant in
vitro selected eye slits and Liliana
Losada
has headed a project here in
collaboration with david sequencing
these clinical item isolates in projects
that were funded by NIAID so with that
presentation has concluded and open for
any questions
so the first question is asking for a
little bit more information on how how
the TN seek works because I guess it
wasn't completely clear the way I I
described it so the key is that that
with TN seek you have a very large
library that that that contains
transposon is inserted in virtually
every gene in the genome in some of the
clones within that library so the
libraries of set of clones that have
been transposed to put loss-of-function
transposons into genes with individual
members of the population and then then
it's just simply a competitive growth
assay through the Selective conditions
so you you have your initial library
that you passing to under drug selection
and under the drug selection the members
of the library which are more resistant
will grow faster and they'll you'll have
a larger abundance of those clones after
passage and you'll see those more often
because you'll actually count the
numbers of individuals in the library
that have a transpose in the gene at
issue
so if transposon is knocking out a gene
that actually in the absence of that
function it's more resistant they'll
grow faster and the inverse is of course
true that if you knock out a gene that's
essential for resistance at that level
the the it'll grow more slowly and so
you'll see its population within the
library decline and so you'll see those
scoring fewer numbers after passage than
before and so it's it's really
if you adjust the numbers of cycles so
that you don't get too many really
maladapted insertions totally eliminated
from the population you'll get a very
powerful measure of the fitness
contribution of the genes under the
passage conditions which will give you a
very broad view of all the genes that
are playing in the phenotype in the
phenotype of course is resistance or
sensitivity to the drugs and and those
that play in the resistance if there'd
runnable then they can become candidates
for drug development projects so I don't
see any other questions anybody do you
have any last-minute questions you'd
like to ask
so if if there's no further questions I
just like to mention that you will
receive some subsequent information if
you are interested in the the continuing
education credits and with that I thank
you for your attention and and I
appreciate the opportunity to really
give you this lecture thank you very
much